veronique asks you say to put out
quality content daily can I add curated
content to my own content if yes what's
the right mix the thanks so much for a
great first question I I'm really
excited by the way I've been really
missing the show between the weekend and
traveling to LA and st. Louis on Monday
and Tuesday big shout out to everybody
who's listening on the podcast oh I said
watching I didn't say watching and
listening on the intro that's just how
it is sometimes
anyway the answer to your question is
absolutely as a matter of fact I think
what I call DJing the ability to take
content that's going on all around the
world right now and bring it into your
voice and putting it out there is an
enormous skill set
I think it's mapping what's happening in
the actual music world right you look at
what's happening in EDM and other places
that nature DJs people that are able to
take a lot of different things and put
them together it's really like being a
great chef isn't it so actually I think
one of my biggest weaknesses is my lack
of curation right because I take so much
pride that the content is mine I haven't
gone out and and taken you know articles
from other people and then like you know
kind of jumped on top of that I remember
loving tumblr one of the reasons I
invested in tumblr way back when was the
notion of reblogging right like tumbling
something you hit you hit somebody
else's blog post and then you wrote your
two cents on top of it the retweet
functionality with a quote and then
you'd put your own two cents on Twitter
I think still has a lot more potential
they like limit you to room I love the
ability to retweet and then have 140
characters and let the whole thing be
250 characters Twitter you should steal
that because I think that would make
Twitter much better I think the adding
of two cents has always been something
that I think has been valuable and you
look at somebody like Guy Kawasaki I
mean if you go look at his Twitter feed
it's all curation right he treats
himself like a media company it's almost
not him it's like the Guy Kawasaki you
know a network and he's just putting out
hundreds of tweets a day it feels like
of just different articles things of
that nature kind of like a human nuzzle
or or or a kind of like a human RSS feed
so I think curation of other people's
stuff or or passing on other headlines
is the biggest weakness in my social
media content
game and I highly recommend all of you
working on it and if he feels
comfortable for a lot of people you know
I would say my here comes a humble brag
and I'm doing a lot of that lately if
you didn't see the latest video I like
the dynamic pause don't at it so for me
I think the reason I don't do as much
curation is I have the ability to do
original content at scale that's a
struggle for a lot of people so for a
lot of people that don't know what to
say the curation of other content and
being the news source for somebody and
the rest of the world under there
context with the nares onra is you know
if you're a yoga person or a health
person or a pumpkin picker you know your
two cents on Apple pay or or George
Clooney's wedding or things of that
nature under the context of being a
puffle Punk pumpkin picker matters oh
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe